bonsoir à tous deux invités ce soir dans
ce spécial preuve par trois entre deux
tours des élections législatives d'abord
des films bateau bonsoir ministre
délégué à la justice ce qui a triomphé
dès le premier tour dans les deux sèvres
dans l'ex circonscription de ségolène
royal et puis ensuite philippe marini le
président ump de la commission des
finances on l'attend sur la question des
déficits publics mais aussi du front
national à propos duquel il est plutôt
décomplexé avec moi ce soir sujet de
blocs de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire et perrine tarneaud de public
sénat et vous bien sûr les
téléspectateurs par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque d'orange
delphine batho d'abord ségolène royal
donc on le sait est en grand danger pour
cause deux duels fratricides à la
rochelle et puis il y a eu cet
incroyable rebondissement ce tweet qui
tue de valérie trierweiler est ce que
vous demandez com
jean louis bianco de quoi elle se mêle
valérie trierweiler est une femme
indépendante
donc sa parole n'est pas celle d'une
responsable politique elle n'engage ni
le président de la république ni le
gouvernement ni le parti socialiste elle
a émis une opinion personnelle qui n'est
ni la mienne ni celle du gouvernement
je crois qu'on ne peut pas dire comme
vous venez de le faire qu'il y à une
sorte de duel fratricide à la rochelle
parce qu'on pouvait dire qu'il n'y avait
aucune compétition au premier tour entre
la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle légitime ségolène royal
est un dissident
olivier falorni mais ce duel a été
arbitrée par les électeurs de gauche au
premier tour est ségolène royal qui l'a
emporté tête en tête du premier tour et
qu'il est donc en situation de devenir
la députée de la rochelle et donc cela
me permet de dire que la candidature
d'olivier falorni a changé de nature
entre le premier et le second tour et 2
il est devenu que le candidat soutenu
par la droite soutenus par dominique
bussereau et ségolène royal et l'accord
du président de la république on a
d'autant plus de mal à comprendre la
position de valérie trieweiler un appel
je voulais dit elle n'est pas une
responsable politique c'est un appel de
ma part aucun commentaire ce n'est pas
une responsable politique mais elle vit
quand même avec le président de la
république françois hollande qui est
intervenue pour soutenir
le t'exprimer l'a clairement pour
soutenir ségolène royal comme comme nous
tous d'ailleurs et vous savez ce qui
compte parce que les rochelais sont des
citoyens libres ils vont pas voter en
fonction d'un tweet ils vont fonctionner
en fonction des projets en fonction de
la qualité des personnalités du bilan
qui est celui de ségolène royal et je
pense que ce qu'ils font comprendre
étant élus de la région je peux vous le
dire c'est qu'il y a derrière la façon
dont aujourd'hui olivier falorni est
devenu le candidat soutenu par la droite
une volonté de dominique bussereau qui a
été sèchement battu par ségolène royal
aux élections régionales ségolène royal
qui avait aussi battu jean pierre
raffarin en 2004 il ya une volonté de la
droite d'essayer de battre la présidente
de la région poitou charentes dans cette
élection législative royal de rockstore
franchement franchement est-ce que c'est
au niveau de la qualité du débat
politique que les citoyens attendent moi
je moi j'en crois pas en campagne du
président intervient dans un des points
les plus chauds des législatives on ne
peut pas dire que c'est anodin
ça n'appelle pas de commentaires je vous
ai dit c'est une femme libre et
indépendante elle a le droit d'avoir ses
opinions personnelles mais ça n'engage
pas ni le président de la république ni
gouvernement ni le premier ministre ni
le parti souhaitait franchi les limites
de la neutralité selon vous oui
forcément avec ses projets profession
j'ai pas de commentaires à faire je vous
ai dit c'est une femme indépendante
voilà il faut pas gérons pas passer
l'émission sera bien sûr beaucoup de
responsables socialistes sont accablés
c'est votre cas aussi non moi je suis
engagé pleinement derrière ségolène
royal je pense qu'elle va gagner je
pense qu'elle va gagner je pense que
ségolène royal est une des grandes dames
de la vie politique française si je suis
là aujourd'hui devant vous c'est aussi
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours
donné sa chance aux nouvelles
générations et ça oui bien sûr wisekey
laisser sa circonscription de louis elle
m'a donné cette chance en 2007 de faire
mes preuves par moi même et d'être
maintenant élu au premier tour et ça
c'est quelque chose là entend lancer
dans la vie politique on pouvait en
témoigner delphine batho ps qu' elle
même ne sait pas donner les meilleures
chances pour atterrir à la rochelle elle
a refusé une primaire socialiste non
elle a quitté la chute âge finalement
non non elle n'est pas parachutée en
valeur dans sa propre région vous pouvez
pas dire que ségolène royal est
parachuté elle a été investie par le
parti socialiste avec notre soutien à
tous dans une circonscription où il y
avait déjà une difficulté on le savait
entre le maire de la rochelle le député
sortant maxime bono et olivier falorni
qui n'a rien voulu entendre
c'est dommage pour lui et c'est dommage
pour celui qui était un militant
socialiste de n'avoir aucun embarras à
être aujourd'hui soutenu par la droite
dans la façon dont il l'est mais vous
dites qu'elle va gagner mais là on
visage et ceux des fêtes aujourd'hui
disant qu'elle ne quittera pas la
politique de toute façon parce que c'est
une combattante ségolène royal donc
c'est normal a répondu à une question
qui lui était posée mais moi oui je
crois je pense qu'elle va gagner parce
que tout le monde dans notre région
connaît l'extraordinaire travail qu'elle
a fait pour l'excellence
environnementale pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises pour les jeunes
apprentis et cette capacité de travail
elle est prête aujourd'hui à la mettre
au service de la rochelle et de la
république aussi dans des fonctions
parlementaires apporte en effet si elle
n'est pas élue députée dimanche je vous
la voyez ou à la tête du parti
socialiste par exemple sont pas toujours
elle sera présidente de région et qu'on
travaille comme présidente de région
mais je veux qu'elle soit élue dimanche
prochain alors bon vous êtes prudent
dans vos commentaires sur le ce fameux
tweet de valérie trierweiler parlons
peut-être de la prise de position
officielle de françois hollande
puisqu'il a rédigé un mot pour la
profession de foi de ségolène royal il
est donc intervenu alors qu'il avait dit
qu'il n'interviendrait plus comme
président dans les affaires du parti
socialiste qu'il est là en contradiction
avec lui-même non c'est l'exception qui
confirme la règle
et il ya une exception pourquoi pas ce
qu'il y a la façon dont un candidat a
voulu semaine confusion qui n'a pas lieu
d'être et on sait aussi que ségolène
royal a joué un rôle important dans la
campagne présidentielle notamment dans
l'entre-deux-tours dans
l'entre-deux-tours aussi des primaires
et donc c'est ça social est le seul il y
a le cas du vaucluse où il ya la
candidate socialiste qui se maintient
malgré les consignes du parti socialiste
se retirer pour laisser la place en ump
désistement rigoler c'est qui cette
situation tout de même différente mais
les situations
qui se présentent comme un gamin comme
un dissident et qui veut battre une
candidate légitime de la gauche avec les
voix de la droite vous savez normalement
la règle à gauche c'est que c'est au
premier tour qu'on arbitre d'éventuels
conflits internes à la gauche est donc
là on est sorti du cadre c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui motive aussi l'engagement
du président de la république si marine
le pen est élue dimanche prochain à
hénin beaumont est ce que jean lui que
je ne souhaite pas est ce que jean luc
mélenchon en portera une part de
responsabilité dont il a placé la
présidente du front national sous le feu
des projecteurs pendant cette campagne
rien n'est joué moi je souhaite que
philippe kemel gagne dimanche et pour
cela il faut que tout ce qu'on votait
jean luc mélenchon au premier tour
votent pour le candidat socialiste au
second tour et donc nous commençons pas
à tirer des bilans avant que le deuxième
tour des élections législatives soient
joués vous savez alors jean-luc
mélenchon lui-même tirs des bilans et
l'état mr aujourd'hui ya seulement 30
sur le post une solution dans laquelle
dans lesquelles il n'y aura pas de
second tour dimanche prochain donc ça
veut dire que dans la majeure partie des
circonscriptions de france il y à un
second tour et donc nous ne faisons pas
les analyses politiques les bilans qu'il
faudra faire en temps utile avant que le
second tour soit joué alors pour
l'instant nous sommes dans une bataille
et dans une bataille notamment pour
battre marine le pen à hénin à propos du
front de gauche et des communistes on
prête à françois hollande eu l'intention
de les faire entrer dans le gouvernement
il y aura un remaniement bien sûr
peut-être qu'avec votre victoire du
premier tour vous serez promu je ne sais
pas déjà un promotion en venait
d'arriver à faire rentrer des cohortes
au gouvernement après second tour des
législatives sous haute tension
c'est une prérogative du président de la
république et du premier ministre qui
examineront cette question certainement
après le second tour moi je n'ai
je n'ai pas de deux à intervenir dans la
composition du gouvernement tic moi ce
que je serai une bonne chose les choses
vous ai répondu je n'ai pas à interférer
dans ce qu'ils sont des prérogatives
vous savez le nouveau gouvernement un
esprit d'équipé un esprit collégial mais
nous voulons aussi
incarner une forme de remise en ordre
des institutions et donc chacun doit
être dans ses prérogatives les
prérogatives du ministre et même du
ministre délégué n'est pas de dire ce
que sera la position du premier ministre
et du président de la république sur la
compression divers mais est ce que en
tant que député socialiste aujourd'hui
ministres au gouvernement en plus des
réchauffeurs nous avaient été réglés
mais vous êtes mise vous siégez pas pour
l'instant est ce que vous êtes inquiète
quand même que les avions pour l'instant
il n'y a aucun cumul oui entre des
fonctions parlementaires et des
fonctions ministérielles savoir sur 23
de la constituante a fait tout à fait
vous avez été élu vous serez sans doute
à nous vous siégiez à nouveau après vos
fonctions ministérielles mais ce que
vous êtes inquiète aujourd'hui de la
situation des alliés traditionnels du
parti socialiste le front de gauche mais
aussi les écologistes qui peut-être
n'auront pas de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale
écoutez on verra sur la base du résultat
des élections nous nous souhaitons une
majorité forte cohérence solide oui un
oui des taux dans la mesure du possible
plutôt une
majorité au sénat aussi majorer diverses
avec toutes les composantes de la gauche
ce serait encore mieux écouter plus il y
aura de l'inviter socialiste il y aura
deux réalités de gauche dimanche
prochain mieux nous nous porterons
pourquoi parce que c'est une condition
pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre le
programme présidentiel sur lequel
françois hollande a été élu si on veut
que la réforme fiscale soit votée que la
loi de programmation pour l'école soit
votée que la réforme bancaire soit votée
il faut une majorité de gauche qui
répondra juste et sa cote est également
bien sûr vous êtes proche de ségolène
royal vous l'avez rappelé vous défendez
l'ordre juste vous incarnez un
un peu la sécurité j'ai envie de dire un
discours un peu musclé est ce que vous
êtes totalement à l'aise dans la
composition à la chancellerie qui vous
fait cohabiter avec créé christiane
taubira qui a été dépeinte par l'ump
comme le symbole du laxisme alors non
seulement je ne courais vite pas avec
christiane taubira mais c'est une femme
que j'admire énormément avec qui nous
allons faire un excellent travail et
même j'espère je crois que nous allons
faire un tandem d'enfer elle est garde
des sceaux moi je suis ministre délégué
auprès d'elle pour veiller sur un
certain nombre de prérogatives précise
qui concerne les droits des victimes
l'exécution des peines la promotion des
droits donc c'est tout le problème de
l'efficacité de la justice le fait que
les décisions de justice souhaite
effectivement suivis d'effets qu'elle
soit appliquée c'est ça le travail que
je vais effectuer avec cristal lui payer
et je veux insister c'est ce que je vous
disais à l'instant sur l'esprit d'équipé
c'est vrai que dans le précédent
gouvernement avec nicolas sarkozy on
voyait les ministres se chamailler entre
eux c'est pas du tout ce qui se passe
dans l'équipe de jean marc ayrault il ya
un bon
oui mais c'est notre volonté cette
collégialité cette solidarité et ce
travail en équipe le premier texte qui
vient finir au parlement sera celui sur
une nouvelle loi sur le harcèlement
sexuel y avez vous travaillé
c'est christiane taubira et najat
vallaud belkacem qui ont travaillé sur
ce texte qui était très attendu
puisqu'il ya eu sa décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui aboutit à une
situation de vide juridique qui est
insupportable pour les victimes de
harcèlement sexuel et donc moi dans les
prérogatives qui sont les miennes ce que
je veux dire c'est que le travail du
gouvernement et du parlement puisque le
projet doivent ensuite à discuter sur un
plan parlementaire qui vise à aboutir au
vote d'une loi le plus rapidement
possible est indispensable pour que dès
le mois de septembre ou à l'automne
prochain une personne une femme qui est
victime de harcèlement sexuel sur son
lieu de travail puisse aller porter
plainte
et puis obtenir la condamnation de ces
comportements vous savez un des
problèmes qu'il ya sur le harcèlement
sexuel comme sur les agressions
sexuelles dans leur ensemble c'est que
de très nombreuses femmes ne portent pas
et moi je veux que les victimes aient
confiance dans la lah 80 condamnation je
crois par an c'est la quantité de
témoignages que l'on reçoit que l'on
connaît de ce qui se passe il faut pas
généraliser justement vous êtes en
charge du droit des victimes
la défense de la défense des victimes et
10 droits des victimes donc comment avez
vous participé dans ce texte puisse
c'est un volet essentiel
là on peut voir justement votre travail
d'équipé avec madame taubira peut-être
en pratique vous dites que c'est elle
qui à cet âge et travaille encore ce
soir il ya d'ailleurs une réunion
qu'elle pilote avec najat vallaud
belkacem avec les associations puisqu'il
ya un certain nombre de remarques qui
ont été faites
une usine à gaz non il ya la volonté
d'une relation et c'est pas simple
maintenant il ya la volonté du
gouvernement d'assurer la sécurité
juridique puisque c'est ce qui a été
reproché par le conseil constitutionnel
d'assurer la sécurité juridique de ce
dispositif mais d'abord y ait un
dialogue qui se poursuit et un texte qui
est déposée il ya le parlement qui va
faire aussi un travail très important
que ce soit au sénat où déjà des
sénateurs proposition de loi sénatoriale
absolument
évidemment il ya un débat parlementaire
vous savez je parlais de la collégialité
cela vaut aussi pour le respect du
parlement qui doit être associée
pleinement aux réformes et ce sera c'est
ce qu'a indiqué à plusieurs reprises
jean marc ayrault qui est lui même un
peu un qui a été pendant tant d'années
un parlementaire chevronné période on
peut lire dans paris match cette semaine
que nicolas sarkozy va bénéficier de la
protection de dix policiers pour un coût
annuel estimé à 700 milles euros est ce
que c'est normal où vous l'avez appris
avant cette émission moi j'ai aucun
commentaire à faire j'imagine que si
c'est le cas c'est qu'un risque a été
mesurée font manifestement à une demande
qui était satisfait de l'ancien
président de la cub et que ça vous
paraît beaucoup consacrée aux dix
policiers pas d'informations et de
commentaires que pensez vous de la part
lundi père de mohamed merah contre l'aso
qui a conduit à la mort de son fils
terroristes meurtriers comme on le sait
il avait annoncé cette démarche l'avait
choqué lorsqu'il l'avait fait donc
tranquillement
mon sentiment c'est que je crois pour
connaître le travail des policiers qui
est un travail tellement difficile celui
des policiers du raid mon sentiment
c'est de leur faire confiance mais si
cela s'est si la justice est saisie elle
se elle se prononcera également bien sûr
est ce que vous seriez allé au chevet du
jeune de villiers-le-bel qui a été
renversé le week-end dernier lors d'une
collision avec une voiture de police le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est rendu à
tottenham oui bien je suis solidaire du
ministère derrière vous comprenez sa
démarche
évidemment très bien
la justice est-ce que vous pensez que le
nombre de fonctionnaires de ministères
logistique dont et trouve montée de
combien il a écouté l'engagement qui a
été pris par le président de la
république c'est que au cours de son
quinquennat 1000 postes seront créés
dans la police la justice et la
gendarmerie donc il y aura prochainement
un travail sur le budget pour l'année
2013 qui sera même un travail
pluriannuel avec la loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui permettra de
dire la ventilation de ces mille postes
entre la police la gendarmerie et la
justice mais évidemment on le sait que
l'institution judiciaire vous savez moi
mon sentiment c'est que de la même façon
que le gouvernement nouveau en arrivant
trouve une situation de déficit public
très lourd de la même façon que dans le
domaine de l'éducation nationale on
trouve un système scolaire qui a été
profondément mis en difficulté par la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
postes nous trouvons un passif dans
l'institution judiciaire avec un manque
de moyens avec une institution qui a été
malmené dont l'indépendance a été mise
en cause avec beaucoup de peine qui ne
sont pas exécutées et avec des
magistrats des personnels des greffiers
aussi auquel il faut redonner
du courage du respect de l'écouté et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec
christiane taubira qui mène un travail
remarquable et notre volonté c'est
d'abord de travail et d'écouté et
ensuite de communiquer vos deux grandes
priorités après la loi sur le
harcèlement sexuel qu'ils seront les
prochains textes concernant la justice
vous savez justement la justice n'est
pas que changer les lois pendant dix ans
nous avons eu une accumulation de loi à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un crime grave
il y avait une loi supplémentaire donc
nous nous voulons te faire un travail
sérieux un travail en profondeur
conduire un certain nombre de réformes
en écoutant ce qu'on attire aussi les
personnels de l'institution judiciaire
et donc nous ne serons pas dans cette
logique d'accumulation des lois nous
ferons des lois utile justement avec
notre avec notre partenaire orange et
l'application tivi tchèque qu'on a une
question qui nous arrive de giovannoni
qui vous demande si en matière de
justice les premières mesures du
quinquennat de françois hollande vont
servir à détricoter la politique menée
ces dernières venaient par nicolas
sarkozy il faudra revenir sur un certain
nombre de mesures par exemple qui sont
inefficaces par les deux on a parlé des
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs
la forme qui sont soit stoppée soit
écornée écoutez l'engagement du
président de la république que nous
avons pris devant les français pendant
la campagne électorale c'est une justice
plus accessible plus efficace il ya eu
une accumulation de textes comme je vous
le disais donc le parlement sera amené à
faire un travail pour évaluer ce qui
marche ce qui marche pas et ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut supprimer allez vous
étiez là d'abord pour parler des
législatives c'est bien cela delphine
batho alors au ni ni de l'ump et répond
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure avec suzette
le front républicain du parti socialiste
met donc dans le seul cas où il pourrait
être appliqué face à marion le pen dans
le vaucluse la candidate socialiste
refuse de se retirer alors là vous
dimanche à un cas pratique dimanche
prochain vous voteriez pour l'ump dans
cette circonscription
il faut battre le front national c'est
ce que l'artiste socialiste a donné
comme consigne dans cette
circonscription c'est dommage que ce ne
soit pas suivi et je voudrais quand même
insisté sur une chose je voudrais quand
même insisté sur le jeu dimanche là il
ya 480 circonscription dans lesquelles
le débat sera entre la gauche et la
droite il ya soixante et une
circonscription dans laquelle le front
national est présent en 1997 il y avait
cent trente trois circonscriptions dans
lesquels le front national est présent
donc je ne veux pas que le débat de
centre de cet entre deux tours soit
complètement monopolisé cristallisé par
cette question qu'est ce qui est
sérieuse que je ne nie pas du front
national alors que la grande question de
dimanche prochain c est ce qu on donne
une majorité au parlement à françois
hollande ou est ce qu ont rétabli les
amis de nicolas sarkozy dans une forme
de situation de cohabitation de
désordres qu'a priori non vous êtes en
ballottage favorable
vous le savez il faut encore que le vote
soit amplifiée dimanche prochain parce
que notre pays traverse une crise
économique une crise sociale et qu'il
faut que le gouvernement et la
légitimité du parlement pour agir un mot
sur le front national quand même
nadine morano qui évoque les valeurs
communes avec le fn et qui donne une
interview à minute ça vous fait réagir
bien sûr on avait déjà vu ça dans
l'entre-deux-tours de la campagne
présidentielle
donc c'est toujours la même stratégie
qui continuait ce qui est regrettable
pour l'ump c'est que cette stratégie de
légitimer de légitimisation de l'extrême
droite qui a conduit nicolas sarkozy à
sa défaite parce que c'est un élément de
sa défaite se poursuivre aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup c'est une bateau on va
parler du front national justement
maintenant avec philippe marini le
président ump de la commission des
finances est sénateur de l'oise où
l'extrême droite a décroché trois
triangulaire dimanche prochain on voit
d'abord l'ondé de choc à l'ump entre la
règle édictée donc par le bureau
politique et puis la tentation d'accord
du côté des électeurs et de certains
élus locaux alors comment s'y retrouver
jérôme radier
confrontés à des triangulaires et un
électorat de plus en plus favorables à
des alliances locales avec le front
national l'ump devait trancher
réunis en bureau politique d'hier le
parti a approuvé et mieux clair pour son
secrétaire général dans tous les cas de
figure nous n'appelons pas à voter pour
le front national naturellement nous
n'appelons pas non plus à voter pour un
candidat socialiste qui a choisi de
s'allier pour gagner avec l'extrême
gauche ni front républicain ni alliance
avec le fn tout le monde semble a priori
sur la même ligne du moins jusqu'à
dimanche prochain et les réfractaires
ont été priés de se taire il a donc été
recommandé de se taire là dessus et de
laisser le parti ou alors on fait pas
partie du bureau politique il est
l'humanisme de l'ump qui affiche
d'habitude sa préférence pour le ps en
cas de duel avec le fn est clairement
visé pourtant dès aujourd'hui certains
élus n'hésitent pas à critiquer cette
stratégie c'est une solution je
comprends mais je ne partage pas je
pense que c'est une solution qui est une
solution de court terme c'est à dire que
ça permettra peut-être de remporter à la
marge quelques circonscriptions
supplémentaires mais je crains que sur
le long terme cette solution aboutisse à
une certaine forme de banalisation de
l'extrême droite qui fait l'album ne
sera pas favorable d'autres élus n'ont
pourtant pas ses réticences à l'image de
nadine morano en difficulté en meurthe
et moselle qui a clairement pelez les
électeurs du front national a voté pour
elle l'ancien ministre de la défense
gérard longuet défend lui aussi un
dialogue avec les électeurs du parti
frontiste c'est un acteur de la vie
politique française à part entière c'est
un acteur clé comme le front de gauche
comme le parti socialiste est un acteur
politique ça il n'y a pas marqué
pestiféré d'ici dimanche et le second
tour des législatives l'ump restera sur
cette ligne politique c'est seulement
ensuite lors de la bataille qui
s'annonce pour prendre la tête du parti
que les langues pourront vraiment se
délier au sein de l'ump voilà philippe
marini le président ump de la commission
des finances nous a rejoint bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous donc avec
toujours suzette bloch et perrine
tarneaud alors quelle est votre position
à vous face au fort au front national
vous avez entendu notamment votre
collègue monsieur lecerf qui dit ce
ni-ni entraîne un risque de banalisation
de l'extrême droite moi je constate que
le front national fait sensiblement
moins qu'à la présidentielle très et
demi pour cent sur le plan national cd
score auquel on est habitué depuis 25
ans alors il ya des plus y'a des moins
mais il faut franchement faire un
fromage la position de l'ump a changé
moi je dis c'est mon analyse personnelle
que l'enjeu de cette élection
législative c'est le nombre de députés
socialistes
je considère qu'il serait très
dommageable à la république que le parti
socialiste et la majorité absolue à lui
danser tout seul à lui tout seul donc
chaque siège est important et moins il
ya de delhi les socialistes il y a deux
députés socialistes et à mon avis mieux
notre pays sera gérée et plus on se
remettra rapidement les pieds sur terre
monsieur chasse 1 qui s'est retiré dans
le vaucluse nouvelle il lui appartient
d'apprécier l'état d'esprit de ses
électeurs et le climat de sa
circonscription je suis un
décentralisateur et
je ne mets pas en doute sa bonne foi et
sa bonne volonté chacin s'est retiré il
appelle à faire barrage à michel
vauzelle qui est aussi le président de
la région paca vous fait le malin appel
que lui moi je ne fais aucun appel je
n'en ai vu que sa position non mais je
dis simplement que s'il y a quelques
députés en nombre très limité du front
national la république va pas être
transformés et que l inverse il parti
socialiste a vraiment tous les pouvoirs
dans cette république y compris le
pouvoir constituant nous serions à leurs
avenants g vous estimez que le front
national peut être un contre-pouvoir
utile mais je n'ai mais ne faites pas
dire des choses que l'on écouté mais
vous ne me faites pas dire des choses
que je n'ai pas dit ce qu'on a compris
j'estime que l'enjeu c'est qu'il y ait
dimanche prochain le moins possible de
députés socialistes d'eau que par
exemple l'élection de marine le pen
serait légitime que les experts qu'on en
a tiré toutes les conclusions que vous
voudrez je vous ai dit ce que j'ai dit
oui bon on a compris que ça y est j'ai
trouvé légitime qu'il y ait
effectivement il regorge de députés pour
l'assemblée nationale à moins de rire un
peu le ps elle doit être représentatifs
des courants d'idées et de pensées comme
l'a dit très justement gérard longuet
les électeurs en question qui ont été
très nombreux aux présidentielles un peu
moins aux législatives au premier tour
ne sont pas des pestiférés ne vous êtes
d'accord un jalon grave je suis
totalement d'accord avec géré alors que
ça lui donnait une interview à minute
ont écouté les
écouter je pense que que s'agissant d'un
hebdomadaire
c'est clos d'ici dimanche prochain dont
au demeurant
sur les sujets de ma compétence je n'ai
jamais refusé d'interview à personne sur
cette stratégie du ni ni de l'ump
certains quand même au sein de votre
parti estime que c'est une position à
court terme c'est par exemple le cas de
bruno le maire ou d'autres sénateurs ici
elle sert aussi par exemple mais nous
sommes un rassemblement très large il y
à différentes façons de réagir et même
de penser dans notre mouvement
j'estime que son unité doit être
préservée à d'audition de court terme
c'est à dire aujourd'hui vous vous
demandez si non mais j'estime qu'il est
parfaitement légitime que dans l'ump il
y ait différentes sensibilités qui
s'expriment
vous avez bien compris que le jeu du
front national c'est d'attirer une
partie de ses sensibilités qui utilise
son propre faute et que donc sincèrement
l'ump est à 35 % le front national est
attrait et demi le rapport de force y'a
pas photo est ce que une partie de l'ump
n'a pas déjà fusionné dans sa tête avec
le front national comme le dit arnaud
montebourg
écoutez tout ça ce sont des ddv
vaticinations médiatique et et quant aux
alors comment s'appelle le ministère
d'arnaud mon ministère il reste mon
produit que l'on redresse moment du
crime alors il veut redresser les
entreprises et ce qui me semble adresser
les esprits à
redresser les esprits je lui laisse ces
tendances que je trouve alors mes amis
les marines et qu'est ce qui a changé
depuis les cantonales de 2001 alors hein
on s'en souvient alain juppé françois
fillon ou nathalie kosciusko morizet
défendent est le front républicain est
plus aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé eh bien vous m'aviez interrogées à
ce moment là je vous aurais dit je ne
choisis pas d'accord mais vous vous
étiez en quelque sorte un précurseur
nommé higuain moi j'ai ma liberté et
j'aime l'ump je suis heureux de
représenter l'ump d' exercer une
responsabilité pour l'ump parce que
c'est un groupe libre où on peut
s'exprimer
dans l'avenir nous aurons des tendances
qui seront organisés et il y aura un
congrès ou en toute transparence les
idées vont s'exprimer et les organes
dirigeants seront élus comme on doit le
faire dans un parti démocratique
à partir de liste de programmes et
documents d'orientation et ça aurait
toujours dû être comme ça alors pourquoi
pas des alliances locales côté et
je vous ai dit ce que je vous ai dit moi
il y aura
socialiste et mieux se portera la
république d'accord donc alors bienvenue
à quelques députés front national pour
faire pièce à leur niveau 1 c'est ce
qu'on comprend de vos propos encore une
fois vous êtes marine une dernière
question sur le sujet diriez vous comme
dang dinh dinh morano que vous avez vous
partager des valeurs communes avec le
front national côte est le premier à
avoir dit ça c'était vers 1986 était
charles pasqua ah oui et vous savez que
j'ai gardé beaucoup de tendresse charles
pasqua allez vous avez livré aujourd'hui
même fini par une charge contre les
projets de françois hollande est-ce que
la situation d'après vos informations et
avant même que soient connus l'audit de
la cour des comptes est ce que la
situation est plus urgente que jamais
pour les finances publiques oui bien sûr
quels sont vos informations les finances
publiques sont dans un état critique
et nous avons le devoir de renforcer de
défendre la crédibilité de la zone euro
nous ne pouvons le faire qu'en affichant
et en respectant une discipline total
tient pas revenir à 3% de déficit public
à la fin de 2013 on y arrivera c'est pas
moi c'est pierre moscovici qui a dit
très récemment le nouveau ministre est
que pour l'année 2012 nous dérivons que
nous sommes des as déjà dans une
tendance vers 5 à 5,2 pour cent alors
que 4,5 était prévu donc un correctif
sera indispensable je voudrais
simplement qu'on nous dise pour combien
quand d'accord le réel qui fera les
sacrifices bien d'impôts supplémentaires
combien dépensant moins aussi demandé un
délai supplémentaire à nos partenaires
on peut reporter un petit bout et les
chats est bien gentil mais ceux qui se
sont appliqués la rigueur et la
discipline dans un ami allemand sur qui
tout repose je veux dire l'allemagne
elle a fait les efforts elle s'est
restructuré
lcl à changer de comportement ça a été
douloureux elle a envie de payer pour
les autres et on les comprend et si on
était à leur place on tiendrait une
position très ferme alors pierre
moscovici le ministre des finances lui
dit on peut arriver à cet équilibre sans
mesures d'austérité est ce qu'il est
crédible quand c'est une question de
mots
il va falloir prendre des mesures pour
améliorer le solde améliorer le solde
sans austérité dutil cela veut dire soit
augmenter les recettes
soit diminuer les dépenses et faire une
combinaison entre les deux c'est
inévitable alors maintenant
si une augmentation des impôts vous êtes
pour mais je dis que la vie me condamner
l'augmentation et parle de matraque à
l'augmentation des recettes des
prélèvements les dîmes et une
est une nécessité d'accord mais la
diminution des dépenses également une
nécessité et c'est une affaire de
proportion moi j'ai simplement repris
vous savez et j'ai diffusé un document
de travail très détaillé ce matin c'est
transparent tout le monde peut le
consulter il est maintenant sur internet
j'ai repris les chiffres qui sont dans
les engagements de françois hollande qui
sont dans les documents du parti
socialiste avec le programme de
stabilité que nous avons approuvé au
mois d'avril c'est à dire la projection
triennal et c'est très proche des
chiffres de françois hollande bon j'en
déduis qu'avec le ralentissement de la
croissance avec la difficulté à tenir la
norme de la dépense publique il va
falloir prendre des mesures
supplémentaires 10 milliards
d'ajustement en 2012 et 20 milliards en
2013 alors avec ou sans austérité ça ça
dépend du gouvernement mais si l'on veut
parvenir à 3% de déficit public afin de
13 ce qui est la condition de notre
notation du coût de nos emprunts
crédibilité il va bien falloir trouver
cet argent françois hollande vient de
dire que la croissance ne naîtra pas de
dépenses publiques supplémentaires s'est
rassuré
écoutez ça me paraît ça me paraît assez
évident mais en même temps
il avait laissé entendre qu on
rechercherait le salut de l'europe avec
des dépenses européennes supplémentaires
et des projets bones pour financer des
investissements
d'infrastructures j'ai regardé quels
montants 4 à 10 milliards pour les 27
pays de l'union européenne
est ce que vous croyez que ce sont des
chiffres et qui sont significatifs pour
la croissance française c'est peanuts en
tous les cas il défend toujours ses
investissements européens une aria tort
il n'a pas eu la preuve mais laissez pas
de ça que notre croissance va venir et
est ce que vous voyez quand même une
inflexion heureuse pour vous dans son
discours effectivement quand devant le
conseil économique et social et
environnemental le chef de l'état et dit
que la croissance ne naîtra pas de
dépenses publiques supplémentaires
heureuse lucidité heureuse lucidité mais
maintenant si j'étais un électeur de
gauche ce que je ne suis pas j'aurais
entendu tout un discours pendant des
mois et des années et puis au moment où
arriverait les actes de gouvernement
peut-être que je ne me retrouverais plus
parce que l'ajustement de 10 milliards
qu'il va falloir faire avant la fin de
l'année 2012 pour moi c'est le même
montant que le plan fillon de septembre
2011 mais vous l'encouragez bien sûr
dans cette voie et bien entendu parce
que soit on reste dans l'euro soit on en
sort et on dit pourquoi faire et pour
rester dans l'euro il faut être crédible
on défend notre rating est sérieux et
par conséquent aboutir à nos engagements
respecter nos engagements vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires et vis-à-vis de ceux qui
nous prêtent de malheur vous saluer
l'heureuse lucidité du chef de l'état et
en même temps vous dites ça va être la
gueule de bois pour les électeurs de
gauche je dis simplement que l'on
veuille bien aller au bout de la
transparence ont fait voter nos
concitoyens dimanche prochain
sans leur dire la vérité à temps dans
l'audit
elle est bien bonne l'audit a bon dos
nous avons reçu la cour des comptes il y
a deux semaines qui a dressé l'état au
31 décembre 2011
ce qu'elle nous dira au titre de 2012
très peu de chances d'être différent et
nous avons par ailleurs les observations
de la commission européenne qui sont
parvenus le 31 mai sur le programme de
stabilité que le précédent gouvernement
a adressé au mois d'avril du couple nous
avons toutes les informations du coup
pour avoir cette transparence à ce que
vous allez convoqué très rapidement
après le deuxième tour des législatives
les ministres des finances et du budget
devant votre commission ici au sénat
pour avoir des éléments sur la future
politique du gouvernement bien entendu
cela va de soi et c'est déjà prévu le 20
juin la semaine prochaine nous allons
élire un nouveau rapporteur général on
nous dit que ce serait mon excellent
collègue du finistère en soi marques
dont nous allons naturellement
travailler en binôme puisque la
commission des finances est une
commission donc à une majorité petite
majorité mais une majorité que je
respecte elle a un rapporteur général un
président nous avons une seule et même
équipe de collaborateurs donc même si
nous pensons différemment salon
travailler ensemble comme j'ai eu le
plaisir de travailler avec des
politiciens des éléments du collectif
budgétaire qui n'est heureusement pas
rien tout je ne sais quels sont les
contours de collectif
je ne sais pas comment la matière
fiscale en particulier va être partagé
entre le collectif et la loi de finances
pour 2013 dont les arbitrages montée de
fait au cours de l'été et qui sera
adopté par le conseil des ministres au
mois de septembre il y a beaucoup de
questions qui se posent dans tous les
domaines fiscaux fiscalité des
entreprises fiscalité de l'épargné
fiscalité des personnes
fiscalité du patrimoine
qu'est ce qui va être dans le collectif
qu'est ce qui va être dans la loi de
finances mais n'avait reçu aucun
document
non aucun document ce normal écouter les
nouvelles autorités sont là depuis peu
de temps mais moi je n'en souffre pas
particulièrement j'ai une très grande
patience mais je me mets à la place des
électrices et des électeurs qui vont se
prononcer dimanche prochain et je pense
qu'ils auraient le droit de savoir très
bien au delà des quelques indications
assez vagues qui ont été donnés il
aurait le droit de savoir ce qu'on va
faire et avec quelles conséquences
votre homologue de l'assemblée nationale
sera bientôt de votre couleur politique
les marinistes que vous avez une
préférence pour écouter tout le monde
sait que j'ai eu un très très grand
plaisir à travailler comme rapporteur
général pendant de très nombreuses
années avec gilles carez donc moi
naturellement mon voeu c'est que nous
poursuivions ensemble beaucoup d'autres
prétendants valérie pécresse voilà
françois baroin voilà bon niveau grande
idée donc l'écouter moi je ne veux pas
je ne suis pas député donc c'est le vote
ce sera le vote du groupe ump de
l'assemblée nationale moi mon voeu est
il est très clair c'est de poursuivre
l'excellent travail en commun que j'ai
fait pendant tant d'années avec gilles
carez parce que c'est un garçon qui est
indépendant qui dit ce qu'il pense
qu'ici parce qu'elle
nomme écouter écouter non non non non
gilles carez est quelqu'un qui travaille
beaucoup qui fouillent les choses et
qu'il écrit et qui ne parle de rien sur
quoi il n'est pas une conviction fondée
par leur mobile au sérieux votre
fréquentation des anciens c'est le cas
justement écouter tour icaunais écouter
écouter
j'avais en fait les reee pécresse qui a
vraiment un bon et un brio
extraordinaire décidée mais dans ce rôle
je préfère gilles carez ceci dit c'est
pas moi qui veux tu vas y que je serais
arrivé heureux de travailler avec le
président qui sera là à l'ail est une
question qui nous arrive de notre
partenaire orange avec l'application
tvcheck la gauche pourrait voter est ce
que la gauche pourrait voter vos
propositions de taxation des géants du
web alors j'ai observé sur ce sujet une
assez nette convergence dans les
analyses qui ont été faites par nicolas
sarkozy par françois hollande lui-même
par sa spécialiste du sujet devenu
secrétaire d'état fleur en fleur
pellerin
mon but dans ce domaine c'est de
travailler à une prise de conscience de
la situation inadmissible
inéquitable dans laquelle se trouvent
les over the top et très grande
entreprise multinationale d'origine
américaine qui utilisent opportunément
et toutes les ressources de la fiscalité
et du droit pour se localiser en irlande
au luxembourg aux îles caïmans ou
ailleurs il faudrait contrôler tout ça
est ce que vous dites il faudrait
surtout que l'on me dernis notre
fiscalité parce que si l'on voit
échapper de la fiscalité les assiettes
les plus modernes est celle qui
progresse le plus qui va payer ce sont
les autres etc l'inéquité la plus totale
ça pourrait rapporter combien ça écoutez
l'enjeu sur les années qui viennent est
un enjeu en milliards d'euros deux
petites questions en rapport avec le
parti socialiste le premier ministre
jean-marc ayrault déclare que l'ump
prépare une alliance stratégique avec le
front national que lui répondez-vous
mais mais mais mais c'est une cc cc
c'est une vue de son esprit ccc c'est
évidemment écoutez comment voulez vous
que l'on puisse imaginer une chose
pareille
bon maintenant je
voudrais savoir s'il ya des électeurs de
voter ouvrière de lutte ouvrière qui
votent pour un candidat socialiste
est ce qu'il ya un accord stratégique
entre lutte ouvrière est le parti
socialiste même avec le front de gauche
est ce que sur tous les sujets il y à un
accord stratégique et en particulier sur
ceux dont nous venons de parler c'est à
dire la nécessité d'être sur les 3% dont
à la fin de l'année 2013 est ce que le
parti comme premier ministre c'est grâce
à bulle le 1er mai nous sommes dans une
semaine préélectorale
chacun fait ce qu'il peut avec ses beaux
bien entendu mais là je pense que le que
le premier ministre est vraiment très
très loin de toute réalité crédible
perrine nous a occupés à la rochelle
opération il faut sauver le soldat royal
branle bas de combat françois hollande
est intervenu aujourd'hui martine aubry
étaient sur place et puis patatras en
milieu de journée un tweet de valérie
trierweiler la compagne de françois
hollande est tombée elle soutient le
camp l'autre candidat socialiste
dissident face à ségolène royal mais moi
je pense que les affaires de famille où
les liens personnels non pas à jouer de
rôle en politique on a trop reprocher
souvent à juste titre à nicolas sarkozy
d'être trop influencée par sa fille
personnel et par sa vie de couple pour
accepter cela d'une autre manière et
dans d'autres circonstances je respecte
beaucoup la personnalité de madame tri
relais l'air que je trouve élégante
séduisante qui est une femme libre et
qui a le sens de ses responsabilités
mais pour autant elle n'est pas mandaté
elle n'est pas élu pour prendre une
position de cette nature surtout quand
on peut imaginer qu'elle serait
peut-être motivé par un tout petit peu
de ce sentiment si compréhensible de
jalousie la jalousie j'allais vous
interrogez c'est la jalousie qui est
derrière tous et je n'en sais rien moi
je ne lis potez et crédible pour vous je
ne saurais sonder les reins et les
coeurs et je ne connais pas le sujet
mais mais c'est ce et c'est à cela que
ressemble cette déclaration merci merci
et c'est regrettable
merci à vous philippe marini d'être venu
ce soir dans preuve par trois merci
bonsoir à tout ça très vite
en 2005 samsonite fabricant américain de
bagages ferme son unique site français à
hénin beaumont dans le pas de calais
lusine reprise par un constructeur de
panneaux solaires dépose le bilan 18
mois plus tard les salariés licenciés
sans indemnités dénonce une machination
juridico-financière pas un seul panneau
solaire qui a été fabriquée sur le site
rehnab ou paas donc c'était des panneaux
solaires ont été apportées d'allemagne
pour faire croire au personnel que on
pourrait en faire mais cette pauvre
liquidation totale ou la longue bataille
judiciaire de salariés contre un géant
industriel un documentaire d'hélène
desplanques samedi à 22h sur public
sénat suivi d'un débat animé par élise
lucet
chaque année 70 mille personnes sont
hospitalisées sans leur consentement
alors que la loi qui encadre ces
hospitalisations vient d'être réformé la
réalisatrice lorène debaisieux a enquêté
sur le monde de la psychiatrie
j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui
me semble encore très tabou
je pense que la folie fait peur encore
aujourd'hui et que j'avais envie de
parler des fractures de la société s'en
fait partie et je pense que c'est une
manière de décrire la société que de
raconter comment la société traite c'est
fou c'est un ange en turquie ou dans des
prisons aussi c'est une façon de voir
quel est le niveau d'une société
exactement par là de voir comment elle
gère à la marge les personnes ne font
pas dans le circuit de pala commun sur
river liberté c'est un enjeu important
parce que il ya à peu près 70 mille
personnes qui sont hospitalisées sous
contrainte par an et que ça correspond à
peu près au nombre de personnes qui sont
incarcérés équivalent donc c'est vrai
que c'est comparable l'enjeu est
important et nous voilà nous semblait
important de donner la parole aux
personnes concernées parce qu'à ce qui
est dur dans l'histoire mais vous êtes
la mère d'un enfant comme ça qu'on
demande à hospitaliser c'est quoi c'est
la trahison qu'on semble lui faire c'est
la peur de se tromper c'est quoi là je
n'avais pas peur de me tromper toute
façon je suis pas tout seul dans le gag
c'est une mère ne veut pas hospitaliser
son enfant de force il n'ya pas l'avis
du psychiatre donc il ya des médecins
qui vous appuyez ou chivu
qui disent oui mais il n'ya pas que vous
vous vous le demander mais bon ce qui
est c'est vous voyez votre enfant partir
dans une ambulance en ayant une piqûre
calmantes de force dans la fesse voilà
il vous suivez vous arrivez en pleine
nuit dans un hôpital
psychiatrique que ça soit sainte anne où
paul guiraud d'autres c'est quand même
un peu style asile du 19e siècle donc
voilà ma fille me disait tu m'as fait
interner chez les fous non je t'ai fait
hospitaliser parce que tu es malade et
tu as besoin qu'on l'a reproché
boozer fois c'est terrible pour pour
avoir la conscience après récupérer elle
peut elle comprend pas elle veut pas et
puis petit à petit petit à petit il ya
quand même
une espèce de compréhension que ça n'est
pas vraiment pour lui faire du mal et
que l y trouve aussi elle a fait la
démarche elle même parfois d'y aller
seul vous en même temps aujourd'hui elle
est au top et des nations libres à quoi
bon si c'est ça le choisit d'y aller oui
donc c'est une évolution dans son
entraînement et dans son état oui il
serait une locale admis qu'au fil du
temps que vous l'ayez fait le bon choix
que d'appeler des médecins pour la
contraindre à se faire soigner oui c'est
ça oui en gros c'est ça oui
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
on rentre comme ça hospitalisée la
demande d'un tiers ou d'office dans un
hôpital on n'est pas libre on est
enfermé on est contrat on est attaché on
à la mairie dans une chambre et quoi on
est avant tout protéger c'est le mot
mais concret viendront la vérité c'est
quoi pour protéger ma vérité des faits
mais dans toute la médecine il ya des
mesures qui sont prises quand on reçoit
quelqu'un qui est à moitié dans le coma
on va pouvoir on va prendre toutes les
dispositions pour qu'ils se fassent pas
de mal en tombant nous nous devons faire
en sorte que puisqu'il n'est pas
conscient des troubles dont il souffre
qu' il ne part il ne quitte pas
l'hôpital immédiatement qu'il ne ne se
fasse pas du mal qu'il ne fasse pas de
mal à d'autres patients enfin c'est
toutes ces mesures devraient encore
selon d'incarcération mais on est on est
qu'à dans une logique de privation de
contraintes on peut on le prenait un
traitement à quelqu'un qu'il refuse on
peut le faire à tous les usages et les
règles on peut le voir ce regard là mais
non mais s'il a passé son crédit mais
c'est une protection
nécessaire et qui n'est pas discutable
puisque l'arrivée du juge c'est très
très difficile à vivre pour les
psychiatres qui jusqu'à présent était un
peu maîtres chez eux et qui sont
maintenant obligés effectivement de
justifier encore une fois la privation
de liberté nous avons eu de longs débats
à l'assemblée pour savoir si le juge
devait aussi intervenir dans
l'obligation de soins il nous est apparu
nous députés toutes tendances politiques
confondues l'obligation de soin à
domicile à l'extérieur extérieur à
quelques nouveautés de la loi aussi un
dépens de vendre obligé déçoit mais là
il n'ya pas le regard des juges pour
l'instant dépendamment de la privation
de liberté il nous a semblé que le juge
n'avait pas à intervenir sur
l'obligation de soin ça c'est le rôle du
médecin ce rôle du psychiatre à côté de
ça la notion de privation de liberté
elle est fondamentale et ça ce n'est pas
du ressort du médecin c'est vraiment du
ressort du juge de
l'avoir je suis venu au patient est en
mesure ou pas de sortie alors ça se
passe plus ou moins bien selon que les
juges se déplace à l'hôpital ou pas nous
avons aujourd'hui dans les auditions que
nous avons mené le premier bilan montre
qu environ 30% des juges se déplace dans
les hôpitaux et dans ce cas là ça se
passe globalement très bien est ce
qu'ils comprennent bien vous êtes de
leur côté par en face et comment ça se
passe ce qu'ils sont vraiment s qui
souhaitent qui revendique
ses tresses est très variable à dire
qu'il ya les tout une certain nombre de
patients qu'ils comprennent pourquoi ils
sont là et
toute une autre partie qui n'est pas
d'accord d'ailleurs il ya eu
hospitalisations sans consentement c'est
bien qu'au départ le patient n'était pas
n'était pas consentante mais au bout de
15 jours parce que nous nous intervenons
quand même quasiment au bout de 15 jours
enfin nous plaisait pas et va pas pas
toujours pas toujours pas toujours mais
en tout cas
ce que je vois quand même un certain
nombre de personnes qui n'étaient pas
d'accord pour être hospitalisés qui dix
jours plus tard à beurre à deir balaa et
j'ai eu des ratés mais vous en libérer
en premier mais combien alors il
faudrait saga 6% 5 à 6%
de manu et
évaluations en primaire enfants stressé
par an compétitif l'école est elle en
page ils ont débattu sur le plateau d'
élise lucet
j'ai trois enfants donc deux plus grands
19 et 16 ans et un plus petit qui a 6
ans et j'ai été très frappée parce que
donc les trois on n'a pas changé de
quartier on est resté dans la même école
et à dix ans d'intervalle je n'ai pas
reconnu la maternelle